boom what's up everyone welcome to
simulation I'm your host on shotgun
we are still at koa as the Congress on
the future of engineering software for
our second annual partnership with them
we are now sitting down with Christian
Thompson hello hey pleasure to be here
yeah thanks for coming on to the show
really appreciate it very excited to
talk to you all the way from Denmark
originally yep and now lives in New York
working on end topology and topology
he's doing software engineering physics
and optimization there and topology is
doing really cool work in engineering
software for advanced manufacturing
we're gonna be breaking that down at
Technical University of Denmark
Christian did master science and
engineering design and Applied mechanics
and was also doing research assisting
there so Christian let's start things
off with this with this perspective on
your journey so how did you get
interested in engineering and in design
and software how did you get interested
in these fields yeah so I've always you
know been interested in in how things
work and how you know we can describe
physical phenomena with with models and
had been curious about how yet
technology works and so I think it's
it's natural to go engine engine
engineering that I think that wasn't in
my night you know the most natural thing
for me to do and so I have so after high
school you know I went directly into the
technical inversion of Denmark where I
decided to I was I wasn't quite sure
whether I wanted to go with math or with
mechanical engineering but ultimately I
decided to go with mechanical because it
also had some you know physical aspects
to it so you know you model real-life
things and you know I saw that as being
you know the way I could provide you
know most value create mode you know the
biggest difference and so I like to you
know see you know abstraction that's a
good thing but I also like to you know
see that it actually you know the things
I'm working on actually has an impact on
on you know the things that the work
that you do has an impact on the and the
industry and you know and so so after
after I started that universe to wasn't
sure you know whether or not I wanted to
go with the traditional route or or I
wanted to do more math or I wanted to do
up to my station but after some time you
know I I was really inspired by you know
the way you you know how how we with
computation with we we are able to set
up models which allow us to you know use
computers to actually derive design so
take the manual take the manual steps of
a design process a way and let the
computer do the work because you know
technology is evolving so fast and
there's definitely an opportunity here
for us to to use that to our advantage
and I think that's really what what got
me interested in optimization in general
and also you know so in order to make it
usable you know and put it in into a
real product and and have solve real you
know solve real problems you know you
also need to you know it needs to be
available in you know in a CAD system or
in a you know in a you know in an
engineering software way so that I think
this combination was really what sparked
my you know interest for for computer
you know software and you know
simulation driven design and yeah and
you know all these things yeah yeah
looking looking back at you first
picking up your interest based on your
desire to understand how things work yes
this is a very frequent thing that we
hear from the engineers and the
designers at all and in even just you
know this insatiable curiosity from
young people is that if you have that
and you can't ever culture it you you're
always so excited to learn you'll go
very far in life you've got to keep
learning and keep understanding how
things work and then if you really get
to the level that you did which you also
got into the mechanic
Engineering side of things the
mathematical side of things the
computational side of things that's when
you can also do things like you're like
you're doing now with optimization
exactly it's interesting to think about
this and I'm interested to hear your
perspective about it which you know I'm
sure will dig into this in a little bit
later but having the computational power
that's now developed over the last like
really 70 years up until the peak that
it's at now to to leverage that to be
able to take away all of our mistakes
that we make also to be able to run all
the permutations much faster than humans
can to figure out which one's the most
optimal functional fit yeah that's it's
it's amazing to see you know how much
potential various in utilizing the
computer to figure out you know how
should we navigate this huge design
space additive manufacturing is really
has really you know advanced
tremendously over the past years and now
all of a sudden you know we have this
design freedom which we didn't have
before and this is really rare
optimization and these computer-aided
technologies shine because now we have
much more design freedom and puts the it
gives the engineer so many more options
to options to you know more creative
freedom but it also comes with you know
a greater responsibility in terms of
knowledge and decision making and so
that is where I think you know using
computer aided you know technology you
know using these advanced you know
mathematical models can really help the
engineers and ultimately be able to
deliver a product take the product from
in each of the initial phases all the
way to you know production ready in a
much shorter timeframe yeah yeah
and then now when you're when you're
doing this this this this optimization
and you're you know you're studying your
and you're figuring out where you want
to go how do you figure out that you
know New York and then topology and
optimization helping them out with that
how did you how did that transition end
up happening for you yes so during the
the my final year as a graduate student
I was working on developing these
optimization algorithms you know in more
and more academics and academic sense
and so but I've always you know had this
you know this desire to go out and solve
real-life problems and I I think that is
really what kept me you know interested
kept my eye open and searched for
opportunities in the industry and so
after I graduated I worked some time as
a research assistant where I was writing
a paper and doing some research and so
that is where I you know Bradley which
is the CEO of entomology he reached out
to the research group and that's is
where you know I saw my opportunity and
so I got in touch with Fred and two days
after I contacted him you know I was in
New York and so it was an amazing
experience and you know and I was you
know very you know much fascinated by
the tools that they've already developed
but I could also see a potential for
developing more sophisticated up to
myself station algorithms using the the
knowledge that I had acquired in my time
I said you know do research and so I
think that was really what got me you
know yet what transitioned me from from
academia to to anthropology and I
seriously considered doing a PhD but it
is ultimately decided to go with
entomology and it's funny because the
stuff we are doing now is actually
depleting working on bleeding edge
technology and actually developing new
methods so it's more you know almost
like a PhD but up just in the industry
in industry you're not and you're
actually getting paid for its ahead
you're all what you're working on is
becoming immediately available to
translate
to industry this is this is what the
whole we have so much conversation about
what the optimal way to incentivize
Sciences and a lot of times it's not the
PhD exactly yeah exam
okay now teach us about the difference
between the optimization algorithms that
you were working on and then what
anthropology was had already done with
their optimization and then how you're
you know how that's coming together now
yes so what they done before my arrival
at anthropology was lattice based
optimization so they could do
optimization of these you know lettuce
truck so they have a a I would say they
have a great amount of tools available
to generate lattice structures and they
also had some tools to simulate them and
and also do the optimization but and
lattice structures are mostly with
material science wise or whatever so it
did you can consider them on multiple
levels so what you can do is you can use
various homogenization methods to
actually consider them as materials and
that is something I'm working on now
actually okay but what they did
beforehand was just considering it as a
lattice structure so that when they
model them they actually just look at
them as beam elements in a similar way
as you know conventional mechanical
engineering engineers model let's say
truss structures show crane structures
and so on yeah yeah and so that by
instead of considering you know that you
know use only considering the lattices
as beam elements that you know puts a
restriction on you know the the scale by
which you you know you can
let's if you if you had a structure of
let's say 100 million people in limbs
then you wouldn't be able to to model
that with with those techniques in a
very efficient way so we looked into
okay how do we make how do we make a is
there technology out there which allows
you to simulate them much more
efficiently and also allow you to
simulate more general
material structure so let's say Jairaj
structures honeycomb structures these
auto trouble or these foam foams and and
so in order to simulate those you know
you have to look to other methods and
that's actually some of the stuff I'm
working on now but so that was one thing
and another thing was we've also been
doing again we try to develop a whole
range of different generative design
process or generative tools to allow the
engineer to you know to design parts and
so while the optimization is another
thing that we've been looking into so
you know many companies do it out there
and we recognize that you know we are
not the company which goes out there and
close all competition away because yeah
that is not our purpose we more seat up
all the optimization you know as a part
of the in part of its it's a tool in the
toolbox socially and it's not an
end-to-end solution yes so we have that
functionality but it hasn't been you
know how a main focus and I've also been
working on developing that you're really
conquering a niche as the best aiming to
be the best tool on the tool belt in
that niche and you're not the whole tool
belt as some people are trying to be
just a little bit so so so what we are
trying to do is essentially so we are
right now what we're working on at in
topology is an engineering platform
where we enable engineering workflows
and engineering process try to capture
engineering processes in just in one
framework all the way from early design
phases using generative design tools
through simulation so we can also you
know perform actually perform simulation
and validate the performance of the
structures to manufacturing so actually
exporting them so we are trying to
develop right now we are trying to
develop this this framework where we can
capture the entire engineering process
in one unified system and ultimately you
know the the whole you know idea behind
this is if you look at you know
conventional ways the way people do
design nowadays you know we have the
workflow is so disjointed you know you
do CAD in maybe SolidWorks and then when
you want to do analysis you have to
bring in two answers or abacus and when
you've done the simulation there maybe
you'll figure out I need to do some
changes in in banking in my CAD model
and so all these times you know I have
to navigate or submit information from
one system to another and it's really a
tedious process where manual labor where
the engineer he uses a lot of you know
valuable time he wasted waste a lot of
valuable time which he instead could
have been used on actual real
engineering work correct and so that is
really what we are trying to do try to
you know get rid of all this you know
not nest
this the you know try to true to get rid
of all this unnecessary work and try to
automate you know these tedious tasks as
much as possible by combining all the
steps you know into one unified system
and then the one the main one that you
just talked about a moment to go was the
the CAD with the simulation software yes
so that when you want to make a tweak in
the simulation so after you don't have
to go and make the tweak back and
McCadden then re-import against a
simulation how how are you then merging
those two so the way we do that is in
terms of what we use is we use fuels so
you can consider anything in terms of
feel so what we have in entomology we
have a you know one of the special
things about entomology is that we have
an implicit geometry candle to represent
geometry so it's not the conventional
way of represented geometry where you
have boundary representations but
instead we what we do is we use math to
represent geometry and what that really
allows us to do is to very you know to
so that is essentially you represent
geometry in terms of the field and also
if you look at simulation data you can
also consider that as fields and so by
having almost this unified language as
you know just one field we can very
easily cover these different you know
steps of the engineering design process
into into an automated workflow and get
rid of all the the array or the the very
tedious tasks careto enable maximal
creative engineering time exactly so so
what how do you label a you said it's a
it's a geometry Colonel yes that is it's
so you're so like a geometry you would
give numbers to and that would be and
then when I would tweak that geometry
the math the numbers would change yes so
actually one way you could think of it
is let's say you have a sphere so if you
want to represent that in our geometry
Colonel the way you would do it is you
would represent it in terms of you know
the equation for a sphere so it is x
squared plus y squared plus s squared
minus the radius and that essentially
defines the sphere and what this really
also allows us to is store objects in a
very lightweight format and that is also
you know brings us to maybe one of the
other very interesting things about you
know what we can do and that is generate
huge you know huge lattice structures or
these periodic structures in a very
lightweight format lightweight formats
so for example you know in our system
we'd be able to generate lattice
structures of hundreds of hundreds of
millions of beams and be able to note
them almost instantaneously that's
really interesting yes and so I think
that's really you know one of the strong
points of our system and implicit
geometry channel and it's on us of
magnitude faster than you know what you
can do elsewhere so it's yeah yeah
interesting in it so it's to do due to
the light weight of your tech but the
light weight of your tech is due to the
geometry kernel which then just is
assigning light like the x squared plus
y squared plus Z squared minus the
radius yes for a sphere you're giving a
value to the X the Y and the Z and the
are yes and the final and the
answer yes you're given that that those
five numbers of and the five this this
final this this way of storing it yeah
it gives you a whole sphere yes and that
way you can load that and it'll give you
the wholesaler in the and that's why
when you make the change to it it'll
change it mathematically exactly yeah
okay and it also has a number of other
benefits so for example you know
traditional you know in traditional cabs
you know some typical operations are you
know if you wanted to do boolean s-- or
you wanted to let's say you have a box
here and you have a lettuce sitting
combined with with the with the your
structure it could be let's say you have
a sandwich structure so you have a solid
plate and you have a lettuce and you
have a solid plate you could use that to
maybe to make a very lightweight part
okay and so for those cases you know if
you if you use conventional CAD systems
and you wanted to have a continuous
blend between the lettuce and the solid
then you would manually have to go in
and click on each of the if each of the
different beams in the connection point
in extra moisture and you can imagine if
you have a solid or if you have a
lettuce comprised of hundred thousand
beams that quickly becomes an impossible
task you wouldn't be able to do you can
make a script right for that process but
the thing is that with implicit with
this implicit geometry kernel what we
can actually do is we can do that it's
it's it's natural to the system so we
can do by it we can do the blending with
on the underlying math so what what this
means is that we can blend in a matter
you don't have to do anything you just
have to you know the blending is defined
in inter it's drawn on the math
equations and so what this means is that
you can do a plan which never fails and
it's done fully automatically and so
this really gives you again you know it
removes the tedious you know parts of
the design process you don't have to
write a script you don't have to
manually click on all the buttons and
this really also means that you can you
know in your design process you can
quickly iterate through so let's say you
figure out I need to make it look that
it's just a little bit bigger or a
little bit wider everything is done in
an automated fashion
you don't have to go through that you
know it just works and I think that is
you know one of the you know the
powerful aspects of the geometry panel
and then your optimization that you were
doing and then are bringing to in
topology is optimization within this
geometry kernel yes that's correct
and so it is part so partly it is just
conventional topology optimization as
you see out there but we are also
looking into optimization using these
these cellular materials so for example
you we can talk about Jairaj structures
or we can talk about lattice structures
or honeycombs of these various forms and
such materials have actually shown to
have excellent performance they can
provide material they you know if you
assume out sufficiently you can actually
consider them as materials so if you
have enough of these periodic this
periodic assembly of shai rods you can
actually consider them as materials and
what this means is that by going in and
locally changing how the microstructure
of these these cellular materials go you
are changing the microstructure of these
cellular materials you can actually
locally change how they respond their
material macroscopic material properties
and what this allows us to do is
actually tap into material regions which
we haven't been able to before so for
example we can make materials which are
extremely lightweight with very high
strength to weight ratio materials which
isolate have a very good isolation
properties materials which dampen energy
in a very efficient can absorb energy in
a very efficient way and so obviously
you know these using these materials in
mechanical engineering design is
obviously you know very it has a huge
potential and so what we are working on
now is figuring out how can we do
optimization using these material
structures and so yeah that's some of
the stuff that we are working on now and
you know the thing is with these
materials that is that
and compared to conventional materials
you just have okay you have a finite
number of materials that you can pick
from but the thing is with these
materials is that you have so many more
much so much more option because now you
can also go in and locally change maybe
how thick should the beams be what
orientation should they be how big
should the cell size be and so figuring
that out is not trivial and so what we
are working on now is trying to figure
out ways in which we can guide the
engineer through the the process of
designing with these and building out
workflows which enable an engineer to do
so this is so cool okay all right so how
would do you guide the engineer through
the through the process you gave the
examples of okay used to be just
different materials then it became well
now you can go you can kind of
double-click and go in and see all the
connection points between those two
plates and the lattice in there yeah
yeah so so how do you guide the engineer
to then to see for themselves that oh
wow that's an interesting way that
anthropology is guiding me to learn that
I can make this more functionable and
the desire that I wanted to so there are
many different ways in which you can do
this and one way would be to actually
use the same method such as we use for
Chabal the optimization so automated
optimization procedures to figure out
how the distribution of these micro or
the cellular material should be and so
that would probably be the you know the
most you know general the fastest way
after are you constantly running the
optimization of the cellular materials
in the back in the you were constantly
running the simulation in the background
and then saying this would be more
optimal yes so it is run in the exact
same way as you you know run
conventional optimization processes and
so the way this works is that you set up
your design space you say okay this is
my design region here I have some here I
fix it here I fix it then I apply some
external loads and then I say it must
meet certain requirements
so for example the stress must not
exceed a certain value in this region is
Earth or the displacement might not be
greater than some value in this region
and you say it must also be lightweight
and it yeah you set up these various
constraints of the optimization problem
and essentially the once you have set up
the optimization problem and defined you
know the Oval constraints and objective
yes then the underlying optimizer all
inputs into your exactly circle so this
would be the user which sets up and
defines the problem and the optimization
algorithm then figures out how the
failure material structures reasoning
should be a beauty ok so there's not
there's there's not even a chance for
then an error really you're rolling with
you're simulating out all of the
accessibility 's and giving the best the
thing is the thing is that if an
engineer were to you know he has the
engineer has so many different
parameters that he can come he can play
with and it can really you know it's
really an overwhelming you know it can
really be an overwhelming you know
experience because yeah there are so
many different parameters that you can
you you can control and so what we are
trying to do is set up workflows which
enable engineers to to actually be a
guide in ginger through the you know
this vast design space and really allow
the engineers to fully utilize the
potential that these materials have
because they can also be used in a you
know if you if you don't select your
your you know design the cellular
material the cellular structure probably
then it's not gonna be bad it's
absolutely not gonna be better than what
you can do with conventional design
methods so you really you know there is
a higher knowledge requirement using by
designing with these cellular materials
but there's also a greater potential and
what we are trying to do is just
enabling engineers to actually tap into
this this this
yeah yeah yeah increased potential
that's right yeah
and this is so cool it it there's both
the the lattice this this the cellular
yeah so sending them men eight matrix
yeah exact so your matrix that can look
like a lattice or a honeycomb exactly
okay Jairaj structure gyro each
structure so cellular matrix so which is
that's where you see the angles of the
different beams that you're exactly and
then that being able to help with that
process and he'll have the engineer say
okay I see why that's optimal it's gonna
have like we asked for all these
variables that's it's it's great and
then can you give us the examples that
you find most relatable for that you
gave a crane as it as an example of
where there's all those beams
yeah right so cranes one of them then
what are other examples where this can
be like applicable understood
so examples where you know I would say
any you know if you want to make
something you know very lightweight but
also very you know highly performative
yes it makes sense to do this so it
could be you know structures which have
you know very high requirements in terms
of weight saving so for example in the
automotive industry or in in the
aerospace industry yeah
and so I think those and those two
industries would definitely be you know
solid ok let me see if I can get this
right then so then the the cellular
matrix in the automotive and aerospace
industries
you don't want extra beams that are
unnecessary
yes you you can remove if you can remove
beams and position them in in more solid
ways to be able to hold to hold it
together and have equal performance yes
you want that because it's useless
exactly so we want to optimally use the
amount of it you know we want to only
make use of the material that we
actually need and so we can use these up
to my station algorithms to figure out
how how that is you know it's
and so they also actually also use it
quite a lot in the medical industry so
there you know these cellular materials
it's partly to do too you know for so
they use it in the medical industry for
implants so they can actually that's it
if you want you need your hip replaced
or something like that what they do is
you can have a custom Lee made a 3d
printed you know hip implant inserted
into your body and what what you want is
of course it has to be lightweight and
that is really where these cellular
materials will make sense and another
thing is you know it also has to you
know fit into your body and and and with
these you know cellular or these
cellular structures the bone can
actually grow into the grow into the
entry into the 3d printed cellular
structure rather than red body rejected
exactly except you want waste for the
body to actually incorporate it and
exactly yep and so I think you know
really there is you know so many great
opportunities to to adopt this
technology and I think you know the
reason why we haven't seen it before now
is because because additive
manufacturing has really evolved a lot
over the past years and so this wouldn't
really have been possible if you just go
back to 10 or 15 years yeah because you
would need to take and the the piece of
raw material you have and try and and
actually carve out yeah and you can
imagine how that would have been if it
was just if you hadn't simply of or you
had to structure your comprise stuff
just even thousand big beams wouldn't
even be possible yeah yeah and so I
think I'll without it if it's it's you
can you can you can make the tweak yes
yeah yeah yeah yeah additive
manufacturing has really you know it's
the driver for you know what we are
doing now yeah it's yeah it's and it's
also you know a great motivation because
3d printing is one form of additive yes
that's correct
that's correct and the other popular
forms um additive yeah
so I'm not so much into a wonderful
evening
I wonder what else are like the other
popular additive manufacturing forms yes
I mean 3d printing and then I don't know
maybe something related to biology it
could potentially be like an uh yeah
form of additive yep yep exactly
essentially like cell division yeah
stuff yeah exactly yeah and so I think
um you know we are in an interesting
time right now because you know if you
go back 20 years it was manufacturing I
was the you know the limiting factor of
the you know the evolution of technology
you know cat software you know was on
the forefront
whereas now over the past ten years we
have seen that that the that the you
know the manufacturing scene has evolved
much faster than the cat software
interesting and so now we are in a
unique position where you know we are
actually lacking behind and that is also
why I think it's so interesting to work
at anthropology because now we have a
unique opportunity to actually you know
enable design you know we have such
great you know opportunity we the design
space is almost unlimited now and you
know now we have the opportunity to
develop tools which actually enable the
engineer to to to tap into this yes yes
Christian couple questions on the way
out one of the questions is you know
we're here at Co Fez and there's so much
cutting-edge engineering software
including yours where do you see this
all converging and going oh that is a
great question and I think over the next
couple of years you know we will
definitely see improvement in you know
the the technology so Tebaldi
optimization and you know just generates
have designed tools it you know those
will definitely evolved because those
are still you know they are not into in
solutions now and they still I would say
they are still in their infancy and so I
think over the next year's we will see
you know we you'll see you know with you
know the increasing you know
yeah the compute power is just growing
exponentially right now and obviously
that helps a lot but I also think you
know we'll see more methods development
in these generative design approach or
strategies and I think that will you
know move the technology to a stage
where it's also easier for for less
experienced people to you know to get
into the industry and I think you know
that is probably also the biggest
barrier of entry right now you know that
you're you still need you know some
level of you know technical
understanding to actually be able to
operate and make sense of these tools so
I think you know over the next maybe ten
years you know we'll see a larger
adoption due to advancement in the
underlying technology and the compute
power yeah yeah the democratization
exactly fascinating getting it into the
hands of younger and younger people
exactly now um
last question is what would you say is a
important or maybe even the most
important skill for kids and for even
adults to learn going into this
exponential technology age so I think
obviously have being curious is it's
very important I think and but even more
so I would say now in terms you know if
it's just a technical skill I would say
programming it it's really amazing to
see you know how much being a learning
this skill from a young age how much it
can do for you because you know you can
essentially solve all problems with with
programming and then you can later on in
in your you know in your life you know
pick up on you know the more advanced
skills such as you know these
mathematical skills and understanding
the physics but I would say even from a
young age just getting started on
programming is probably you know the
best advice I can give that you know
it's it's it's such a powerful tool and
you can really solve so many problems
with it and pretty much all the systems
that we see today you know have some
form of programming you know involved so
I think having that skill or learning
that skill from a young age would
you know we yeah that's probably the
best I can advice I can give yeah that's
great curiosity programming powerful -
yeah yeah definitely Christian thank you
so much for coming back to the show
this has been a pleasure it's been a
huge pleasure right yeah and this is
like you know the way you've taught us
about about what you're working on with
optimization and what what anthropology
is doing is is is really beautiful it's
it's really well you did a great job
explaining it and we greatly appreciate
everyone for tuning in huge thank you
we'd love to hear your thoughts in the
comments below check out Christians
links and typologies links below
also check out co fezzes links below as
well support the artists and
entrepreneurs that you believe in our
links are below simulations links are
below get more conversations
thought-provoking conversations about
things like what we talked about into
our communities inspire the next
generation of people to build the future
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you so much thank you for tuning in
and we will see you soon